سكروها وصلنا نستعمل طرق ترابيه اغلقوها
الاخرى كان ابو اسامه سيصل الى ارضه من
هنا
لولا ان الاحتلال قطع الطريق عليه بل اغلق
الطرق امام مئات من اصحاب الاراضي في
المنطقه المعروفه اي1 شرق القدس المحتله
ثم زعم انها اراض متروكه ثم اعلن مصادرتها
على اساس انها متروكه هم بيوضعوا الصعوبات
امامنا للوصول للاراضي واستصلاحها
وضعوا البوابه ووضعوا المكعبات الاسمنتيه
منعونا بكل الطرق للوصول من اجل اعلانها
اراضي متروكه وبالتالي وضع اليد عليها
كاراضي دوله
الحرف الاول من كلمه ايست اي شرق وهي اراد
تابعه لعده بلدات فلسطينيه شرق القدس
المحتله توصف بانها بوابه القدس الشرقيه
والادق انها البوابه الاخيره لاي تواصل
جغرافي بين شمال الضفه الغربيه وجنوبها
ولامكانيه اقامه دوله فلسطينيه وفق حدود
الشرعيه الدوليه
ولهذا تماما تعارض جهات دوليه عده ابرزها
الاداره الامريكيه اقامه مخطط استيطاني في
الموقع وللسبب ذاته تصر اسرائيل على اقامه
المخطط لتوسيع مستوطنه معالي ادوميم
عند البدء في البناء في اي وان سيحاصرون
الفلسطينيين بين الشرق والغرب ويربطون
المستوطنين بالقدس وبنظرنا هذه مرحله
اخيره
[موسيقى]
حلت دولتين
نجوان سمري الجزيره شرق القدس المحتله